marriage is about something bigger than
yourself you are supposed to submit and
obey your husband it is always supposed
to be about the family it's never about
you your feelings are unimportant you
should not rely on your husband to meet
your quote unquote emotional needs you
don't you're not supposed to have all
these freaking boundaries with your
husband it's your husband you're
supposed to trust your husband with your
life we are so backwards or we will
trust men to be the father of our
children the most important job ever
will trust these men with our bodies but
we won't trust them to make decisions we
won't trust them with our money and we
always need to have a backup plan in our
heads when we trusted these men to
Father our children how crazy how
backwards is that